humans can take a lot of things
you know cold weather hot
hot weather but one thing they cannot
tolerate is humiliation they bounce back
much of what is happening throughout the
world is a revolt against the elite you
know revolt against the privilege and
it's not only in developing countries
you can see that also in development but
people are really frustrated because the
elite has become very insensitive the
lifestyle has become insensitive the
illite in sri lanka they lost confidence
in sri lanka they left the children left
they never had two legs in sri lanka and
that is what triggered this
unrest it was an unrest where you had a
serious gap between the elite and the
common people
now with the technology that you have in
your hand you can actually see the
lifestyle of the ellipse they can see
elite almost in front and they know
that this uh elliot is
culpable or is responsible in some of
the misdeeds and the sufferings and is
mocking
those who are
not in that elite platform the main
lesson from sri lanka would be whether
uh the elite
can actually keep uh its two legs uh in
in its own country and not to humiliate
people by having a lifestyle where
people would feel humiliated that the
elite is humiliating the human is
mocking at the poverty is mocking at the
poor that is unacceptable then you will
have a serious unrest now one way to do
that is how you
link up with the diaspora so that they
can also keep on reproducing the economy
back home because what is happening now
as it has happened in sri lanka it was
not only a brain drain there was also
acid drain the asset was going you know
outside that needs to be a stop the
elite those who have one legs all
out can actually help and develop a
village how you can make a hospital in
some of the remote areas because that
interaction is possible largely because
of the technology that we have now
in order to
make elite
more sensitive
uh
it is the elite which has to do the work
i otherwise the general masters
would
not have the patience because i think
they have seen the world
and they would take things in their hand
these are some of the lessons i think
they can take from
you